country music and grabbing your partner
for a dose IDO you probably have a fuzzy
memory of trying to master these moves
in middle school gym class am i right so
why were we all forced a couple up and
endure this embarrassment well it's all
thanks to Henry Ford now grab your
partner in dosey doe he was the father
of the car and the assembly line but
here's a little-known fact Henry Ford
loved to dance especially with his wife
Clara square dancing has deep roots in
American culture dating back to colonial
times it remained popular until the
waltz in polka went mainstream in the
19th century so in the 1920s for took it
upon himself to revive the old tradition
let's do it y'all he opened a Ballroom
in his hometown and encouraged his
factory workers and their families to
take part he felt square dancing helped
teach manners exercise values and grace
soon after he worked to create a
national square dancing program Boards
of Education across the country started
endorsing Ford's mission and since then
students have been taught to square
dance today 24 states still love square
dancing as their official state dance so
if you feel like reliving awkward gym
class moments I'm sure you can find
square dancing lessons somewhere nearby
I'll jump up and never come down swing
you a pretty girl round and round
you